a man who's always all over all of these
things from the mmq be Peter King how
are you Peter rich Steve how you guys
doing we are hanging in there
so Peter walked me through what you have
gleaned of of John dorsey's mind set to
pull the trigger on Baker Mayfield
number one overall relatively speaking I
think there was unanimity inside his
organization number one to pick Mayfield
that includes you know that includes and
I have not spoken to Hugh Jackson but I
will you know before the end of this
weekend but it certainly includes a
scouting staff like Scott McLuhan who
they've taken on who is obviously a big
Baker Mayfield backer Eliot Wolf we
brought in from Green Bay I think that
this is a big surprise outside the
building that this is the decision they
reach and in the draft Nick community
it's not a big surprise inside their
building were you surprised
nothing surprises me anymore in this
short time because of how how much
evaluations the people fall in love with
players and fall out of love with
players based on various reasons and how
they interact with them increases that
faction or decreases it and I think they
fell in love with them based on the
interview and watching them and watching
the film and how quickly you think he's
going to start Peter first blush you
know I think it's going to be a long
while you know this team obviously is
still going to lose some games
I think Tyrod Taylor you know they say
he's going to be the quarterback this
year he's going to be the quarterback at
least the first whatever quarter or
third of the season problem I think with
putting Baker Mayfield in the game in
the games too quickly is that he's just
going to get beaten down this is a team
that is four and forty nine since
Thanksgiving of 2014 you know they're
winning the winningest quarterback over
the last four years is Johnny Manziel
it's just you know it's it's why why
feed this guy to the Wolves quickly just
to satisfy fans who who are desperate to
win and the fans who have put up with an
incredible amount do it the right way I
don't know what that right way is you'll
have to find out but you've got to do it
the right way and that is not to rush
Baker Mayfield into the game Steve Smith
senior here to my left
live at the NFL draft day to Peter King
of the mmq be on the phone all right
walk me through what the Giants were
going through at the ten minutes on the
clock when the name Baker Mayfield put
the question of darn 'old and Berkeley
in front of them and then the phone
calls that they might have been
receiving to get out of that pick I
don't know what I don't know if they got
any calls rich but I don't I don't think
they've gentlemen ever had any intention
going into this draft that's doing
anything but taking the running back
right there and so it seemed like it was
done quickly I don't know how many how
many minutes the Giants took but I would
be surprised if they entertain
to any offer at all for that tick
because they were going to take Berkeley
all along I think I think the two
biggest things rich that happened here
and the things that surprised me is that
number one I don't think the Browns got
any serious traction or any serious
attempts to trade for the fourth overall
pick that surprises me I don't think
that either Denver Indianapolis ever
seriously considered a deal in part
because I think teams just weren't
willing to give what Kansas City and
Houston gave last year for pepra for Pat
mahomes and and deshaun Watson
I thought Arizona made a great not a
good but a great trade in going up from
15 to 10 and not only not given a future
one not even given a two and you know
for to move up those five spots to get
the last of the four quarterbacks and
Buffalo I wrote about this today you
know Brandon being the general manager
of the bills convened a meeting
yesterday morning inside the facility
with everybody there even down to the PR
guy Derek Boyko and said we got to
investigate everything right now in the
next couple hours about Josh Allen and
then they got Josh Allen on the phone
who Brandon being told me cried during
the explanation of what happened with
those tweets whatever five years ago so
and I think they were obviously
satisfied enough to trade up to number
seven to take him Josh Allen was their
guy all along I believe if the Buffalo
Bills had the first pick in this draft
they were taking Josh Allen do you think
when you said that of the Cleveland
Browns didn't receive any viable offers
do you think that had to do with pic and
Baker Mayfield
then the Giants going with say Quan
Barclay there was no reason for anybody
to move because the true God that that
would have made people jump I believe
probably was Sam Donald Wright and the
Jets were not moving out of three
correct yeah and I think that Steve I
think that's a really smart thing a
smart way to look at it by the time you
got to number four with Mayfield and
with darn 'old off the board did anybody
really want to pay
deshaun Watson kind of value or Pat
mahomes kind of value for two
quarterbacks that were both viewed as
flawed characters in fact every one of
these quarterbacks in this draft was
flawed it's like what Sean Payton told
me a week or so ago that every single
one of these quarterbacks is flawed and
if he had to get four or five years from
now there'd probably be only one of them
in his eyes that you know would truly be
a franchise type guy and that would be
darn 'old I mean that was I do think I
do think that there were not clean
profit and and I thought for a split
second when the Saints traded back in if
you will the Pat mahomes and or Watson
type price tag to trade up and give up a
first round of next year I thought that
that was for Lamar Jackson and I thought
of that quote that he gave you Peter I
thought man man man it was a smoke
screen but then again he didn't come up
for Lamar Jackson how surprising was
that Marcus Davenport pick to you last
night
I mean it just shows me that the thing I
think that they are gonna win the Super
Bowl is sometime in the next two years
they want it to load up they gave an
awful lot for Gavin important I can tell
you that I cannot find you know I talked
to I've talked to maybe six people since
midnight last night or 11:30 last night
I can't find anybody who says man that
was a great trade
everybody likes Davenport but boy to
give up you're you're one next year and
significant stuff this year I think
people thought that they overpaid for
Kevin
that is so funny you said that because
when I was at the compound Peter a lot
of people I said that that part was
overrated they felt that he wasn't as
high playmakers he believed in talking
to Peyton Peyton said I said you believe
that important is worth all of that he
said and more after the trade well you
know we'll see if he turns into a if he
and cam Jordan each gets 13 sacks next
year we're all going to be eating our
words the same great trades because
clearly a great pass rusher is worth two
ones so you know and we'll see we'll see
what happens
all it the thing about judging grabs
that I think is borderline comical is
that I bet I could look at the draft
back in 2014 or whatever the the Manziel
Justin Gilbert year was and I bet you
could look back at that Draft and the
next day and find some smart football
analyst out there saying the Browns had
a great draft I mean it's just you know
you just don't know it's it's foolish in
my opinion to grade draft the next day
yeah I mean JJ Watt tweeted out the
snapshot a screen grab of the Texans
tweet announcing their selection of him
and then the responses beneath and 90%
of the responses were were horrible
picked just awful blah blah blah not
just he left that on his Twitter account
without comment Peter King here along
with Steve Smith on the Rich Eisen show
tonight though which which veteran
quarterback do you think might find
himself in the Flacco position this
evening by night send the quarterback
team rich I'll tell you this I will not
be surprised if the Patriots don't take
a quarterback and the reason is I think
that that the only way if you're the
Patriots you want to take a quarterback
if you view that he's Jimmy Garoppolo or
north of Garoppolo you don't want it you
don't want to take a second round choice
and trade that
around choice in essence for a
quarterback who you think is just a
backup guy so and again maybe the
Patriots might have a guy in time but if
you if you don't see the Patriots take a
quarterback I believe that it means that
they just don't think any of the guys
left on the board have value you know
have the kind of value that they could
see them that quarterbacks starting in
2020 I think the only other team that
you know is going to be interesting to
watch as far as sort of a future
quarterback pick now that Baltimore has
taken Lamar Jackson I just think it's
going to be interesting to see what the
Saints is they don't have a lot of amo
to do it but at some point you know you
have to think that the Saints are going
to invest in in a long-term quarterback
and and again now that Jackson is gone I
don't know who that is going to be for
them well I was saying I was just saying
to joel Klatte that it would be
fascinating if the Patriots choose a
quarterback using the pick they got in
the Jimmy Garoppolo trade tonight just a
really it would be great basically
trading Garoppolo for kiowa letter or
something like that which I don't see
happening but you never can tell
Peter appreciate the time thanks again
break calling a lot you you got Peter
King here from the mm QB he wrote all
about being know with the Buffalo Bills
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience